leigh-anne is with us in Grand Junction
hi Leanne how are you I'm good thank you
and have another show thank you how can
I help my husband and I are 21 years old
and we've just paid off our house and
our credit our cadet but now we're
wondering if we should keep our credit
cards to keep our credit score up or if
there was another way to keep our credit
score up or if we should just do away
with it altogether
how long have you been listening to the
show um I think if I was a little kid my
mom and dad listen to it then you kind
of know the answer to this question
don't you know my dad um so that he also
didn't know because he said that my
credit score is good then you all
haven't done a very good job of
listening to the show uh we'd like to
buy a second house for an investment
property but even with owning our first
house the bank won't give us alone
unless we have a credit score okay so
what was this show this show is about
getting out of debt staying out of debt
as the closest and fastest way to build
wealth mm-hmm okay so I'm not gonna
recommend you buy another house unless
you pay cash for it okay okay and I'm
not going to recommend that you worry
about your credit score 100% of your
credit score ISM there's a mathematical
algorithm that the FICO people use to
create the credit storm okay 100% of the
math that is used to create the credit
score has to do with borrowing money the
only way you have a credit score and
keep a credit score is to borrow money
the only way you have a high credit
score is to continuously borrow money
and pay interest and so a credit score
by definition is an I love debt score
and so since I believe that you should
the bat the the fastest way for you to
build wealth is to be out of debt and
stay out of debt that by definition
means I would not tell you to build and
I love debt score does that make sense
yes okay and so
that means that I'm going to cut up all
the credit cards close all the accounts
your credit score is going to go to zero
like mine has but I'm a multimillionaire
it's worked out for me okay okay well
thank you so much we work we have paid
off all the debt on it and was wanting
to get rid of it but everybody kept
telling us that we'll need credit for
everybody like everybody's broke okay
don't worship at the altar of FICO it's
going to cost you hundreds of thousands
of dollars to keep a score up that is
not an indication of your building
wealth it's only an indication that you
paid the bank a lot of money okay well
thank you so much for your help thank
you I appreciate you calling in hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
you